From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Laura Starecheski, sitting in for Ira Glass. I'd been waiting for months for a certain moment to arrive. Geirid had mentioned it. Chrissy had mentioned it. And here we all were, sitting in their house in the suburbs of DC. We were in their living room. Their son was hopping around with an icy popsicle in his hand.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。我等待这一刻已经几个月了。盖里德提到过，克里斯蒂也提到过。现在我们都聚在她们位于华盛顿特区郊区的家中。我们坐在起居室里，她们的儿子手里拿着一根冰棒，蹦蹦跳跳的。
[EXHALES] This was left in the freezer overnight. Feel it.
[呼气] 这根冰棒在冷冻室放了一整晚了。摸摸看。
And Geirid's laptop was right there-- wasn't open yet, but I was on the edge of my seat. And finally, she asked me--
盖里德的笔记本电脑就在那里——虽然还没打开，但我已经坐立难安了。最后，她问我——
Are you ready for this?
准备好了吗？
I'm ready.
我准备好了。
Chrissy jumped in to hype it up.
克里斯蒂插话进来，烘托气氛。
It's beautiful. It's excellent. Yeah, it's a thing of beauty.
太美了。太棒了。没错，这真是件艺术品。
And Geirid opened the laptop and pulled up a file on her computer called Valkyrie, after the Norse women warriors. They were very into the Thor movies around this time. And suddenly, it appeared, a spreadsheet. Hold for applause. I was looking at many tabs, many rows, many columns, thousands of data points. This is where Geirid is mapping out their whole future.
盖里德打开笔记本电脑，调出了一个名为“瓦尔基里”的文件，这是以北欧女武神命名的。她们当时非常迷恋《雷神》系列电影。突然间，电子表格出现了。掌声响起。我看到有很多标签页、很多行、很多列，成千上万个数据点。这就是盖里德规划她们未来全貌的地方。
We're getting deep into the inner workings of my mind. OK. I'm a data person by training.
我们要深入了解我的内心世界了。好吧，我是受过专业训练的数据分析人员。
And by nature.
也是天生的。
And by nature. This is very much part of my DNA.
也是天生的。这很大程度上就是我DNA的一部分。
It's also part of their DNA as a couple. Spreadsheets are how they make all their decisions as a family. Like, after Geirid finished a PhD in molecular biology, should she go into academia, get a government job? Spreadsheet. She crunched the numbers, decided to rejoin the Navy as an active-duty scientist. She and Chrissy had a whole plan. She'd serve for 20 years, retire, get a pension, health care, a stable life. Where to live, the kids' schools-- each and every one, spreadsheeted with Chrissy's help.
这也是她们作为伴侣DNA的一部分。电子表格是她们家庭做所有决定的方式。比如，盖里德在获得分子生物学博士学位后，是该进入学术界，还是去政府部门工作？用电子表格分析。她算了一笔账，决定以现役科学家的身份重返海军。她和克里斯蒂有一个完整的计划。她要服役20年，退休，领取养老金，享受医疗保障，过上稳定的生活。住哪里，孩子上什么学校——每一个细节，在克里斯蒂的帮助下，都做成了电子表格。
Normally, we're pretty good at doing really concrete game planning. I get on the mental carousel and predict the future, and then she makes a spreadsheet to, like, wrangle it in.
通常，我们很擅长做非常具体的规划。我陷入思维漩涡并预测未来，然后她就会做一个电子表格来理清头绪。
So that's how things normally go. But about a year ago, this family found themselves facing a big, complicated, very uncertain new situation. Geirid's trans and a lieutenant commander in the Navy. And last winter, President Trump signed an executive order banning trans people from the military. The order claimed that trans people are dishonest, unfit, and harm troop readiness.
事情通常就是这样。但大约一年前，这个家庭发现自己面临着一个巨大、复杂且充满不确定性的新局面。盖里德是跨性别者，也是海军少校。去年冬天，特朗普总统签署了一项行政命令，禁止跨性别者从军。该命令称跨性别者不诚实、不适合服役，并会损害部队的战备状态。
Geirid and other trans service members immediately brought lawsuits against the ban. So everyone was in limbo. Are we all about to get kicked out? Are we going to be allowed to stay and keep serving? What's going to happen, and when? There was just so little data.
盖里德和其他跨性别军人立即对这项禁令提起了诉讼。所以每个人都处于悬而未决的状态。我们都要被赶出去了吗？我们还能被允许留下来继续服役吗？会发生什么？什么时候发生？当时的信息实在太少了。
All these hypothetical things that could happen, could not happen, all the stress of trying to play chess around them and plan and spreadsheet around all these hypotheticals.
所有这些可能发生或可能不发生的假设，所有为了应对这些假设而进行博弈、规划和制作电子表格的压力。
Yeah. I mean, you can't make decisions if you don't have information.
是啊。我的意思是，如果没有信息，你就无法做出决定。
No matter. They would make a new spreadsheet and more spreadsheets. They would be on alert. They would be light on their feet. Because something big was coming for them. And they were going to plan and bring all their skill and diligence and available data to be sure that they had control over how this was going to go down. Today's show-- how is this going to go down? This family finds out. And it's not at all how they-- or I-- expected it to go. And another story of two people determined to make the exact right plans for the moment when everything's going to change-- stay with us.
没关系。她们会制作新的电子表格和更多的表格。她们会保持警惕。她们会灵活应对。因为有大事要降临在她们身上了。她们会制定计划，运用她们所有的技能、勤奋和现有数据，确保自己能掌控事态的发展。今天的节目——这一切将如何收场？这个家庭找到了答案。而且结果完全不是她们——或者我——所预期的那样。还有另一个故事，关于两个人决心为一切即将改变的时刻制定出完全正确的计划——请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One, Freak in the Spreadsheets. So we're going to continue to hang out in Geirid and Chrissy's living room, with their kids running in and out as they strategize together. The first time I was there was last March. It was less than two months after Trump had issued his executive order.
这里是《美国生活》，第一幕，电子表格里的怪人。我们将继续待在盖里德和克里斯蒂的起居室里，孩子们在旁边跑来跑去，而她们则一起制定战略。我第一次去那里是在去年三月。那是在特朗普发布行政命令不到两个月之后。
And the little family scene I saw with them stood out to me because one quirk-- let's call it a quirk-- that I've noticed, as a trans person reading all the coverage of Trump's military ban this past year, is that the service members often appear like these islands-- no family around them, no relationships, no community, just a lone, isolated person.
我看到的那个小家庭场景对我触动很大，因为我注意到一个怪癖——姑且称之为怪癖吧——作为一名在过去一年里阅读了所有关于特朗普军事禁令报道的跨性别者，我发现这些军人看起来就像一座座孤岛——周围没有家人，没有关系，没有社区，只是一个孤独、被隔离的个体。
I've talked to a bunch of trans service members over the past year, and that isn't any of them. They all have their people-- spouses, kids, families-- whose fates are tied to theirs, depending on them, like Geirid. She's the main breadwinner here. They've been a military family from the start. Geirid enlisted at 17 and became a Navy diver. She and Chrissy met a few years later. They're both from military families. They have two kids-- a daughter, 11, and a son, 9. Right now, their son has his face in a video game-- zombies, skeletons, lava.
过去一年里我采访过许多跨性别军人，但他们都不是那样。他们都有自己的人——配偶、孩子、家人——他们的命运与这些军人紧紧相连，依赖着他们，就像盖里德一样。她是家里的主要经济支柱。她们从一开始就是军人家庭。盖里德17岁入伍，成为了一名海军潜水员。她和克里斯蒂几年后相识。她们都来自军人家庭。她们有两个孩子——一个11岁的女儿和一个9岁的儿子。现在，她们的儿子正沉迷于电子游戏——僵尸、骷髅、熔岩。
I almost ran myself into a pit of lava.
我差点让自己掉进岩浆坑里。
Don't run into the lava. Life lessons.
别掉进岩浆里。生活课。
This is life. This is big life stuff.
这就是生活。这是人生大事。
Geirid and Chrissy are good at keeping it moving. Chrissy's intense, blunt, but kind of dreamy too. She's an illustrator, loves to paint floaty undersea creatures, a lot of invertebrates. Geirid is smiley and tall, notably tall next to Chrissy. She's got a bob haircut that she tucks behind her ears with great effort. Her hair's always falling in her face. She tucks it back again. Their house is full of nerdy hobby zones-- in the kitchen, historical cooking, with a focus on accuracy rather than deliciousness. Think cabbage stew every single week.
盖里德和克里斯蒂很善于让生活继续前进。克里斯蒂性格直率、强烈，但也有点爱幻想。她是位插画家，喜欢画漂浮的深海生物，很多是无脊椎动物。盖里德总是笑盈盈的，个子很高，在克里斯蒂身边显得格外突出。她留着波波头，费力地把头发掖到耳后。她的头发总是遮住脸，她又把它掖回去。她们的房子里到处是书呆子式的爱好区——在厨房里，有历史烹饪，重点在于准确性而不是美味。想想看每周一次的卷心菜炖肉。
For the last year or so, I've been doing medieval Europe, basically, and have worked my way up from the Viking Age to Tudor England.
过去一年左右，我主要研究中世纪欧洲，从维京时代一直到都铎时代的英国。
Nerd alert.
书呆子警报。
The kids are in and out of the room as we're talking. I'm not going to name them here. We're just going to bleep out their names.
我们交谈时，孩子们进进出出。我不会在这里说出他们的名字。我们会用哔声掩盖他们的名字。
What do you both know about what's going on with your mama's job?
你们俩对妈妈的工作了解多少？
A lot.
很多。
Their daughter, the older one, answers first.
她们的大女儿先回答。
OK. So the thing that I know-- she filed a lawsuit. And then it went through one of the courts. And now she stares at the computer all day. That's all I know.
好吧。我所知道的是——她提起了一场诉讼。然后官司打到了法院。现在她整天盯着电脑看。这就是我所知道的一切。
All this staring at the computer, it's because Geirid's always reading court filings about the ban, and memos from the military, and Signal messages with this whole network of trans service members, who are all trying to figure out what to do. Now their son chimes in.
所有这些盯着电脑看的时间，是因为盖里德一直在阅读关于禁令的法庭文件、军队的备忘录，以及与一个跨性别军人网络通过Signal交流消息，他们都在试图找出对策。现在她们的儿子插话了。
And which is bad for me because [BLEEP] never plays with me, and Mom plays Stardew Valley a lot. And the only thing I know about her job is that she might get fired soon.
这对我来说很糟糕，因为[哔]从不跟我玩，而且妈妈经常玩《星露谷物语》。关于她的工作，我只知道她可能很快就会被解雇。
It's true. This was the situation. And if Geirid did get pushed out, their whole life could go over a cliff, fast. They could be forced to sell their house because they wouldn't be able to make their mortgage payment. They would lose their health insurance, which they really need, because their son has a medical condition that they estimate would cost more than $500,000 a year to treat without it. So it's hard to overstate the existential threat they were living under.
确实如此。情况就是这样。如果盖里德真的被踢出军队，她们整个生活可能会迅速崩塌。她们可能被迫卖掉房子，因为付不起抵押贷款。她们会失去医疗保险，而她们非常需要它，因为她们的儿子有一种医疗状况，据估计没有保险的话，每年的治疗费用超过50万美元。所以，她们所承受的生存威胁怎么形容都不为过。
But Geirid, like almost every service member in her position, was still quietly continuing to do her job. She'd commute to a military research office nearby, spend the day making decisions about where the Navy should invest millions of dollars in research money. None of that work had stopped. So it was like, life as you know it may be about to end, but also, act like none of this is happening.
但盖里德像她那个位置上的几乎每一位军人一样，依然在默默地继续工作。她会通勤到附近的一个军事研究办公室，花一整天时间决定海军应该把数百万美元的研究经费投向哪里。所有这些工作都没有停止。所以就像是，你所熟悉的生活可能即将结束，但你还得表现得好像什么都没发生过一样。
It was dizzying, all this uncertainty. The only way to deal with all of it at once was to develop the most extreme, thorough, multivalent family planning process I have ever seen. Geirid and Chrissy decided that they would make every possible version of a good future for their family come alive. Exhibit A-- a spreadsheet, of course, a sort of "in case of emergency, break glass" spreadsheet, gaming out their options if everything went completely to hell.
这一切不确定性令人头晕目眩。同时应对所有这些问题的唯一方法，就是开发出我所见过的最极端、最彻底、最复杂的多维度家庭规划流程。盖里德和克里斯蒂决定，她们要让未来美好生活的每一个可能版本都成为现实。证据A——当然是一个电子表格，一种“紧急情况下打破玻璃”式的电子表格，推演如果一切完全搞砸了她们的备选方案。
Say Geirid not only got kicked out of the Navy, but also, the overall backlash against trans people in America got even more extreme-- more states passing anti-trans laws, new executive orders targeting trans people. If all that happened, and Geirid and Chrissy decided the whole family needed to leave the US--
假设盖里德不仅被踢出了海军，而且美国国内针对跨性别者的总体反弹变得更加极端——更多的州通过反跨性别法律，新的针对跨性别者的行政命令。如果这一切都发生了，盖里德和克里斯蒂决定全家需要离开美国——
She's developed a very deep and complex spreadsheet of the best places to live, based on her own rubric of quality of life that applies to only our family.
她开发了一个非常深入且复杂的电子表格，列出了最适合居住的地方，基于她自己定义的仅适用于我们家庭的生活质量标准。
What's in the rubric?
准则里有什么？
OK. God.
好吧。天哪。
They needed to find a place where they could make a living, be safe, and have access to specialized medical care for their son. It's a short list but a hard needle to thread. And not only that--
她们需要找到一个能谋生、安全，并能为儿子提供专门医疗服务的地方。这是一个很短的清单，但很难实现。不仅如此——
I'm very particular about data sources and where you get data from. Most of the stuff, it's never clear what the methodology was, how reliable it is.
我对数据来源和获取数据的地方非常挑剔。大多数东西，根本不清楚方法论是什么，可靠性如何。
So frustrating, all the subpar data just floating around out there. So Geirid unearthed sprawling files of original raw data from all kinds of studies. She ran her own analysis on it, tracking quality of life and values, happiness scales, the rights of queer people and women.
真是令人沮丧，到处都是劣质数据。所以盖里德挖掘了各种研究中庞大的原始数据文件。她对自己进行分析，追踪生活质量、价值观、幸福指数，以及酷儿和女性的权利。
I feel like there's something else that I--
我觉得还有什么我——
The weather that we like. 'Cause we're not moving to Malta.
我们喜欢的气候。因为我们不会搬到马耳他。
We're cold weather people. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
我们是喜欢寒冷天气的人。[笑] 是的。
Chrissy and the kids have Italian citizenship, so Europe is on the table. But so are approximately 5,000 other places and subplaces. I couldn't even focus my eyes, looking at it. But Geirid filled me in. So far, the place that's come out on top-- Germany, so far. Geirid was always adding new data whenever she found some, running the numbers again.
克里斯蒂和孩子们拥有意大利国籍，所以欧洲是可以考虑的选择。但大约还有5000个其他地点和细分地区。我看着它，甚至无法聚焦。但盖里德向我介绍了情况。到目前为止，排在第一位的是——德国。盖里德一发现新数据就会补充进去，重新计算数字。
When do you look at it?
你什么时候看它？
Whenever I get super stressed out and I just need to look at some math to calm myself down. [LAUGHS] It's my way of touching grass.
每当我压力巨大，需要看点数学题来冷静一下的时候。[笑] 这就是我“触地”缓解压力的方式。
It's worked in the past, but lately, not so much. What does that look like?
过去这招很管用，但最近不行了。那是什么样子？
Well, lately, it's looked like a lot of crying. And Chrissy doesn't like crying. She--
嗯，最近，看起来就是一直在哭。而且克里斯蒂不喜欢哭。她——
[LAUGHS] I'm emotionally bottled up.
[笑] 我在情感上比较压抑。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So she would find me in bathrooms at 1 o'clock in the morning because I got up to pee and just decided to start crying.
所以她会在凌晨1点发现我在浴室里，因为我起来上厕所，然后决定开始哭。
And I'd secretly roll my eyes but also give her a hug. [LAUGHS] God, get it together.
我会暗中翻白眼，但也会给她一个拥抱。[笑] 上帝啊，振作点。
We'll talk about things, or I'll talk at her about things until too early in the morning. And she either falls asleep or gets frustrated because I'm keeping her awake. And so then I'll be like, OK, next time, I'm just going to keep it to myself.
我们会讨论这些事情，或者我会不停地对她唠叨这些事情直到凌晨。她要么睡着了，要么因为我不让她睡觉而感到沮丧。所以我就想，好吧，下次我还是自己憋着吧。
Which is sad. I don't want you to do that. But we also can't be up till 2:00 in the morning every night.
这太令人难过了。我不希望你这样做。但我们也不能每天晚上都熬到凌晨2点。
Yeah. And I just want my partner to feel my feelings with me.
是的。我只是希望我的伴侣能陪我感受我的情绪。
I do feel your feelings with you. I'm actually really good at it.
我确实和你一起感受了你的情绪。我其实很擅长这个。
You are really good at it.
你确实很擅长。
But you exhaust me. [LAUGHS]
但你让我精疲力竭。[笑]
Here's how fast things were coming at them. The Trump administration banned trans service members from the military. That was last January. They were out. The service members challenged it. They could stay in. Weeks later, a federal judge wrote that the ban was most likely unconstitutional. Stay in. The same month, another federal judge-- I agree. Stay in.
事情发生得太快了。特朗普政府禁止跨性别军人从军。那是去年一月。她们被赶走了。军人提出了质疑。她们可以留下来。几周后，一位联邦法官写道，该禁令很可能是违宪的。留下来。同一个月，另一位联邦法官——我同意。留下来。
Then the Trump administration went to the Supreme Court, claiming it was an urgent matter of national security. All the trans people had to go. Can't we just do this ban now while all these lawsuits happen? Will you allow it? A Supreme Court ruling on that question could come out at any time, which, for Geirid and Chrissy, was like, whoa, we're about to get a real answer on this.
然后特朗普政府上诉至最高法院，声称这是一个紧迫的国家安全问题。所有跨性别者都必须离开。我们难道不能在所有这些诉讼进行的同时执行禁令吗？你们允许吗？最高法院关于这个问题的裁决随时可能出来，这对盖里德和克里斯蒂来说，就像是，哇，我们要得到一个真正的答案了。
And that's when, in their perpetual effort to never be caught off guard, Geirid and Chrissy decided Chrissy would travel to Germany. In May, she got on a plane to see if she could actually picture their family living there. She'd been sussing out job possibilities, checking out neighborhoods and cities-- Frankfurt, Berlin.
就在那时，为了从不被杀个措手不及，盖里德和克里斯蒂决定让克里斯蒂去德国。五月，她登上飞机，看看她是否真的能想象她们全家在那里生活。她一直在探听就业机会，考察社区和城市——法兰克福、柏林。
Tonight, at the bar I went to, called Mr. Susan-- fabulous bar. Everybody should go. [LAUGHS]
今晚，在那个叫Mr. Susan的酒吧，很棒的酒吧。每个人都应该去。[笑]
Great name.
名字不错。
Yeah. Five Americans bellied up to this bar. Like, I was the fifth that walked in. The couple on my right work for the State Department. One of them had just retired. The other one was close to retirement. And they were beside themselves with the stuff that was going on. Everybody's like, do it. Bring your kids here. Get them out of there, which is heartening to hear. It makes me feel like we're not being stupid, we're not being thoughtless.
是的。五个美国人坐在吧台边。我就像第五个走进去的。坐在我右边的那对夫妇在国务院工作。其中一个刚退休。另一个也快退休了。他们对正在发生的事情感到非常不安。每个人都说，去做吧。把你的孩子带到这里来。带他们离开那里，这听起来很令人振奋。这让我觉得我们不是在发疯，也不是在鲁莽行事。
Is there a part of you that feels like you have to justify this idea of moving out of the United States right now?
你内心有没有一种感觉，觉得你必须证明现在离开美国这个想法的合理性？
Absolutely, absolutely. To ourselves, we've had to justify it. It kind of feels drastic. But at the same time, I don't want to be complacent. I don't want to pretend like nothing's happening.
当然，当然。对自己，我们必须证明这一点。这感觉有点极端。但与此同时，我不想自满。我不想假装什么都没发生。
Yeah.
是啊。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hey.
喂。
Where are you?
你在哪？
I'm walking to get the kids. I only have a couple minutes.
我在走路去接孩子。我只有几分钟时间。
Oh my god. I just saw what happened.
噢，天哪。我刚看到发生了什么。
Yeah.
是的。
I called Geirid, because while Chrissy was in Germany, the Supreme Court ruling came out. It was bad news. The Court had sided with the Trump administration. The military could go forward and kick everybody out. So for Geirid and everybody else, this ban that had been looming in a theoretical realm for months was all of a sudden real and imminent.
我给盖里德打了电话，因为在克里斯蒂在德国期间，最高法院的裁决出来了。是坏消息。法院站在了特朗普政府一边。军队可以推进并将所有人踢出去。所以对盖里德和其他所有人来说，这种几个月来一直悬在理论层面上的禁令，突然变得真实且迫在眉睫。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Are you kind of in shock or--
你是在震惊中还是——
A little bit.
有一点。
What's your mental state? I can't tell. I know you also have to be a parent in, like, three minutes, probably.
你的心理状态如何？我看不出来。我知道你还得在三分钟内扮演家长的角色，大概。
Yeah. I mean, it's a little shocking. I think as it's setting in, I guess, as we're talking, it's a little surprising that they didn't even carve out room for the plaintiffs. Because that means that now we're going to be processed out of the military, just like everyone else, before the case even gets back to the Supreme Court to be ruled on its merits.
是的。我的意思是，这有点令人震惊。我想随着我们谈话的进行，我意识到他们甚至没有为原告留出空间，这有点令人惊讶。这意味着现在我们将像其他人一样被处理出军队，甚至在案件回到最高法院进行实质审理之前。
Will you say anything to your kids, or are you trying to spare them from the blow-by-blow stuff?
你会对孩子们说什么吗，还是说你想让他们避开这些细节？
I don't know. I think, yeah, I might talk to them in the next day or so, because they get triggered by all this big time. So I don't want to freak them out about that kind of stuff if I don't have to.
我不知道。我想，是的，我可能会在接下来的一两天内跟他们谈谈，因为他们对这些事情非常敏感。所以我不想在没有必要的情况下吓到他们。
I didn't read the opinion, but I did talk to Geirid about it at length.
我没有读过判决意见，但我确实和盖里德深入谈过这件事。
I reached Chrissy the next day in her hotel room in Germany. It was late at night, almost midnight her time.
第二天我在德国的酒店房间里联系上了克里斯蒂。当时很晚了，几乎是她那边的午夜。
I think she feels a lot of guilt.
我觉得她感到很内疚。
What does she feel guilty for?
她为什么感到内疚？
I think that what she's feeling guilty about is feeling like her transition is creating these problems for us. So I just tried to talk her down a little. And I don't want to catastrophize. I'm trying to look forward instead of getting hung up on what a bunch of bully fucking pricks think about us. Because I don't care what they think. I'm here in Germany with the intention of marching forward.
我认为她感到内疚是因为她觉得她的身份转变正在为我们制造这些问题。所以我只是试着劝导她一下。我不想把事情灾难化。我试着向前看，而不是纠结于一群欺凌人的混蛋是怎么看我们的。因为我不在乎他们怎么想。我在这里，在德国，怀着前进的意图。
Speaking of marching forward, now that the ban was real, here was the military's new policy. Trans service members had less than a month to make a choice-- leave voluntarily, or wait for someone to find you and make you leave. Basically, the Department of Defense was saying, we can do this the easy way or the hard way. You choose.
说到前进，既然禁令已经成为现实，军队有了新的政策。跨性别军人不到一个月的时间做出选择——自愿离开，或者等着别人发现你并强迫你离开。基本上，国防部是在说，我们可以软着来，也可以硬着来。你自己选。
Coming up, Geirid and Chrissy try to find another way. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，盖里德和克里斯蒂试图寻找另一种方法。广告时间后回到芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Laura Starecheski, sitting in for Ira Glass. This is the story of Geirid Morgan and her wife, Chrissy, trying to navigate the military's ban on trans people and keep some control over what's going to happen to their family. So one thing I asked Geirid-- have you ever had any issues with your commanders, your colleagues, since you came out as trans, any problems with anybody serving in the Navy with you? No, she told me, not once-- which is wild.
这里是《美国生活》。我是劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。这是盖里德·摩根和她妻子克里斯蒂的故事，她们试图在军队针对跨性别者的禁令中寻找出路，并保持对家庭未来的一点控制权。所以我问盖里德一件事——你公开跨性别身份后，与指挥官、同事之间有没有遇到过问题，海军里的任何人有没有给你制造过麻烦？没有，她告诉我，一次都没有——这很不可思议。
I asked a bunch of other service members from different branches of the military, different ranks. What was their experience? And overwhelmingly, people said, it was good. I actually got a lot of support. I got a round of applause when I came out to my unit, one Army captain told me. This surprised me because I was at least expecting more of a mixed bag. I'd read a few horror stories. Those were documented in the court cases. But so many people had been serving through multiple administrations without issues.
我问过其他军种、不同军衔的跨性别军人。他们的经历是什么？绝大多数人说，很好。我甚至得到了很多支持。一位陆军上尉告诉我，我向单位坦白时，他们甚至为我鼓掌。这让我很惊讶，因为我至少期待的是参差不齐的反馈。我读过一些恐怖故事。那些在法庭案件中是有记录的。但这么多人一直在不同政府执政期间服役，却没有任何问题。
There's about a decade of experience to draw on, look at, study on how it's affected the military, having trans people serve openly. And it's been kind of a nothingburger, I have to say. I mean, there's been no catastrophic failure of unit cohesion, no indication that trans service members somehow harm troop readiness, as the Trump administration has argued without evidence.
关于跨性别者公开服役对军队的影响，已经有大约十年的经验可以借鉴、观察和研究。不得不说，这完全没产生什么负面影响。我的意思是，单位凝聚力没有崩溃，没有任何迹象表明跨性别军人损害了部队战备，正如特朗普政府在没有任何证据的情况下所声称的那样。
That's been true for years, which is why it was particularly hard to believe that what the Trump administration was claiming about trans people, that was going to carry the day, and not the reality everybody was living in. But now the ban was here, and trans service members had less than 30 days to decide-- would they go voluntarily or involuntarily, the easy way or the hard way?
多年来都是如此，这就是为什么很难相信特朗普政府关于跨性别者的说法竟然会占据上风，而不是每个人都在经历的现实。但现在禁令来了，跨性别军人不到30天的时间决定——她们是自愿离开还是被动离开，软着来还是硬着来？
Presenting just these two unfavorable options is really just such a maniacally effective way to get people to do something they really do not want to do. This is evil genius stuff, mob boss stuff. So I just want to spend a minute on this choice, voluntary versus involuntary separation. Voluntary separation, the first option, would mean you'd raise your hand, self-identify, and your branch would start the process of discharging you. You'd be eligible for an honorable discharge, and you'd get separation pay.
只提供这两个不利的选项，实际上是一种极其有效的强迫方式，让人去做他们真正不想做的事情。这是邪恶的天才手法，是黑帮老大做派。所以我想花一分钟时间谈谈这个选择，自愿分离与非自愿分离。第一个选项，自愿分离，意味着你要举手，自我表露，你的部门将启动退伍程序。你有资格获得光荣退伍，并获得分离补助金。
Involuntary separation-- there was way less information about what that would look like. How exactly would the military find everybody and identify them? Was there any real way to challenge it if they did find you? And if you were pushed out involuntarily and got discharged, would you get an honorable discharge or something else, even a dishonorable discharge? Was that possible? Because that follows you out into the civilian world forever. It shows up on background checks. You can never get any VA benefits. It's a big deal.
非自愿分离——关于那看起来会是什么样子，信息要少得多。军队究竟如何找到每个人并识别她们？如果他们发现了你，还有真正的反抗渠道吗？如果你被非自愿踢出并退伍，你会获得光荣退伍还是其他，甚至是羞辱性退伍？这是可能的吗？因为这会永远跟随你进入平民世界。它会出现在背景调查中。你永远无法获得任何退伍军人福利。这是一件大事。
But those details weren't part of the policy memo. Nobody seemed to know. And there was one more penalty to choosing that path. You'd get just half the separation pay that you would have gotten if you'd gone voluntarily. People had different ways of thinking about this non-choice when I asked about it. One thing that came up was the weirdness of volunteering to not do something, to quit. It went against all their training.
但这些细节不在政策备忘录中。似乎没人知道。选择那条路还有另一个惩罚。你只能获得自愿离职补助金的一半。当我问到这个问题时，人们对这种“非选择”有不同的思考方式。一件事是，自愿选择不去做某事，即辞职，这种感觉很奇怪。这违背了她们所有的训练。
Hank Young is a staff sergeant in the Army at Fort Drum in far upstate New York. He operates artillery pieces. He's served for nine years, done a deployment to Afghanistan. And Hank told me that of the two options, voluntary felt like the only way to have any control over this process. So he'd put in his paperwork, checking the box that said, I'm here, I'm trans, and you can kick me out now.
汉克·扬是纽约州北部德拉姆堡的一名陆军参谋中士。他操作火炮。他服役了九年，去过阿富汗部署。汉克告诉我，这两个选项中，自愿离职感觉是唯一能对这个过程有一点点控制权的方式。所以他提交了文书，勾选了那个写着“我在这里，我是跨性别者，你们现在可以把我踢出去了”的方框。
How did that feel, to be communicating that?
传达那个决定是什么感觉？
It was scary. I weirdly was-- I was actually more concerned-- in my head, I was a little bit more concerned that I was going to get judged for electing to get out than I was for being trans. I really cannot emphasize how strongly the Army frowns upon anybody trying to get out of anything, ever, for any reason. So that was actually probably the part that made me the most nervous.
很可怕。我奇怪地——我实际上更担心——在脑海里，我更担心因为选择离职而被评判，而不是因为我是跨性别者。我真的无法强调军队有多么厌恶任何人以任何理由试图逃避任何事情。所以那实际上可能是我最紧张的部分。
I heard this concern a lot, that leaving voluntarily would mean letting other people down. Everyone felt responsible for the people in their units, the people they supervised, even their commanders. Brianna is a sergeant first class, Army aviation. She's done everything from helicopter mechanic to drill sergeant, two deployments to Afghanistan. She's only out as trans to her family and one close friend and her immediate commanders and was still showing up to work as a male officer. So to protect her, I'm only going to use her first name.
我经常听到这种担忧，即自愿离开意味着辜负其他人。每个人都觉得对单位里的人、自己监管的人，甚至是指挥官负有责任。布莱安娜是一名陆军航空兵的一等中士。她做过从直升机修理工到新兵教官的所有工作，两次部署到阿富汗。她只向家人、一位亲密朋友和她的直接指挥官公开了跨性别身份，并且依然作为男军官去上班。为了保护她，我只用她的名字。
Brianna was hoping to take the involuntary separation. She didn't want to capitulate. But her main worry seemed to be that her commanders could be blamed or punished for not turning her in. She didn't know what to expect.
布莱安娜希望采取非自愿分离。她不想屈服。但她最担心的是，她的指挥官可能会因为没有举报她而受到责备或惩罚。她不知道该期待什么。
I have no idea. I'm honestly prepared for a witch hunt, so to speak. And that's really the last thing that I want to experience myself. And I don't want my commander, an excellent commander, my first sergeant, an excellent first sergeant, or any of my peers-- I don't want to put them in this position of loyalty to the service or loyalty to a human being. So to me, that would be a very compromised and difficult decision to make. And I don't want to do that to them.
我不知道。我真的准备好迎接一场“猎巫行动”了。而这确实是我自己最不想经历的事情。我也不想让我的指挥官，一位优秀的指挥官，我的第一中士，一位优秀的第一中士，或者我的任何同事——我不想把他们置于这种忠于职守还是忠于个人的境地。对我来说，那将是一个非常妥协和困难的决定。我不想那样对他们。
In the end, Brianna decided to take the voluntary too. Most people I talked to did. Geirid is one of the few people I talked to who did not choose voluntary separation. She didn't submit any paperwork at all. She decided to dare the military to come and find her, betting that she could find a way through before they could kick her out, which brings us to act two.
最终，布莱安娜也决定选择自愿离职。我采访过的大多数人都选了。盖里德是我采访过的少数没有选择自愿离职的人之一。她根本没有提交任何文书。她决定挑战军队来找她，赌她能在被踢出军队之前找到出路，这把我们带到了第二幕。
Act Two, When the Bureaucratic Shark Bites. One quick thing I need to say before we keep going-- Geirid and all the service people I talked to did not speak to me in any official Department of Defense capacity. They shared their own thoughts and feelings, their personal views. And the Department of Defense wouldn't answer any of my questions about the military ban. They said they don't comment on ongoing litigation.
第二幕，当官僚鲨鱼咬人时。在我们继续之前，我需要快速说明一件事——盖里德和我采访的所有军人都不是以任何官方国防部的身份与我交谈的。她们分享的是她们自己的想法和感受，个人的观点。国防部拒绝回答任何关于军事禁令的问题。他们说不对正在进行的诉讼发表评论。
OK. So the clock had started. There was less than a month left. Volunteer, or we will find you. Geirid entered this new, intense phase with the same focus she'd brought before. She would master every element of this bureaucracy, watching out for traps, gathering data, staying two steps ahead if she could.
好的。钟声已经敲响了。剩下不到一个月了。自愿离职，否则我们会找到你。盖里德带着她以前一样的专注进入了这个新的、紧张的阶段。她要掌握这个官僚机构的每一个要素，提防陷阱，收集数据，如果可能的话，保持两步领先。
One small example-- once the countdown started, Geirid learned that the military was on the verge of adding a new question to this mandatory health assessment that every service member has to fill out online once a year. The new question would ask if you'd ever experienced gender dysphoria. Basically, are you trans? If you clicked yes, a notification would appear, saying you'd been rendered nondeployable, not fit to serve, and telling you to await next steps.
一个小例子——一旦倒计时开始，盖里德得知军队即将在这个每位军人每年必须在线填写的强制性健康评估中增加一个新问题。新问题会询问你是否经历过性别焦虑症。基本上，你是跨性别者吗？如果你点击“是”，会出现一个通知，说你已被列为不可部署，不适合服役，并让你等待下一步行动。
So Geirid jumped online before they could change the form and quickly filled out the old version before the new question was added. She figured, correctly, that would buy her time. This was the kind of careful maneuver she was executing on four different fronts simultaneously, keeping all the possible realities alive. Scenario one, a court victory-- she and the other plaintiffs win the court case. Could be years away, and sure, maybe they'd all have gotten kicked out by then. But it was still possible.
所以盖里德在他们更改表格之前上网，在新问题添加前快速填写了旧版本。她想，没准那能为她争取时间。这就是她同时在四个不同战线上执行的那种谨慎机动，保持所有可能的现实存活。场景一，法庭胜利——她和其他原告赢得了官司。那可能需要几年时间，当然，也许在那之前她们都已经全被踢出去了。但那仍然是有可能的。
Scenario two, medical retirement-- a while back, Geirid saw a doctor about an old injury that was giving her trouble. And he referred her to be assessed by what's called a medical evaluation board. If the military deemed her too disabled to serve, she could be medically retired. And now that seemed like it could actually be a good option, since the threat of getting pushed out was looming. So Geirid threw herself into this notoriously arduous and unpredictable process-- going to doctor's appointments, getting assessed, putting in a mountain of paperwork-- to document every injury from her service. And then she waited.
场景二，医疗退休——前段时间，盖里德因为一个导致她困扰的旧伤去看医生。医生把她转到了所谓的医疗评估委员会进行评估。如果军队认为她残疾到无法服役，她可以医疗退休。现在看来这实际上可能是一个好选择，因为被踢出的威胁迫在眉睫。所以盖里德全身心投入到这个众所周知的艰苦且不可预测的过程——去看医生，接受评估，提交堆积如山的文书——记录下她服役期间的每一次受伤。然后她等待着。
Scenario three, someone could turn Geirid in, and she'd be forced into the involuntary separation process. Normally, there are options to appeal and make your case if the military's trying to kick you out. Geirid could request to go before a panel of officers called a separation board. But it was unclear if that process would actually help her or just be humiliating. And then after all that, she could just get separated anyway.
场景三，有人举报盖里德，她将被迫进入非自愿分离程序。通常，如果军队试图踢你，是有申诉和辩护的选项的。盖里德可以申请去一个叫分离委员会的军官小组面前申辩。但不清楚那个过程实际上是能帮她还是只会让她羞辱。在那之后，她还是可能被踢走。
Scenario four, Germany, if necessary. She and Chrissy kept up with the house repairs in case they had to sell, had the kids start learning German. I could not imagine, in all my trying, any base that was not covered here, any possible path out of this maze that was unexplored, any blank on any form that was left unfilled out.
场景四，德国，如果必要的话。她和克里斯蒂继续进行房屋维修以防她们不得不卖掉，让孩子们开始学习德语。我无法想象，在我所有的尝试中，有任何未被覆盖的基地，任何这个迷宫中未被探索的路径，任何留空的表格空格。
But the stakes of involuntary separation seemed to keep getting higher. The more time passed, the more Geirid learned. A few weeks from the deadline, Geirid found out about an alarming detail buried in a memo from the Department of Defense. It said that if officers-- Geirid is an officer, as lieutenant commander-- if officers did not self-identify, when they were eventually discharged, they'd get a special code assigned to them. It would go on their DD214.
但非自愿分离的代价似乎越来越高。时间过得越久，盖里德了解得就越多。距离截止日期还有几周，盖里德发现了一项隐藏在国防部备忘录中的惊人细节。上面说，如果军官——盖里德是军官，少校军衔——如果不自我表露，当她们最终被退伍时，她们会被分配一个特殊代码。它会印在她们的DD214表格上。
That's a piece of paper that summarizes your military service. It's an official document. Geirid likened it to a birth certificate. You show it for jobs or to prove you've served. A JKQ code means serious misconduct. BDU means alcohol abuse. The code for trans officers who failed to come forward? JDK.
那是一份总结你服役情况的文件。这是一份正式文件。盖里德把它比作出生证明。你要用它找工作或证明你服过役。JKQ代码意味着严重不当行为。BDU意味着酗酒。那些未能挺身而出的跨性别军官的代码是什么？JDK。
And so JDK is going to essentially designate us as national security risks.
所以JDK将本质上把我们指定为国家安全风险。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And so it was sort of buried in there, and we didn't really know what to make of it. And the lawyers got into it. And it was like, oh, this isn't good. And it was like, oh, shit, this is actually really bad. And it just feels so unnecessary. Like, if you don't self-identify, if you don't make it easy on us, and if you drag this out and make us come and find you, we're going to make it as painful as possible for you and as risky as possible for you. That's the message, I think.
是的。它有点被埋在那里，我们真的不知道该怎么处理它。律师们介入了。然后就是，哦，这不好。然后就是，哦，该死，这实际上真的很坏。感觉太没必要了。就像是，如果你不自我表露，如果你不让我们轻松，如果你拖延并让我们来找你，我们将尽可能让你痛苦，并让你尽可能承担风险。我认为这就是信息。
The JDK code would make it hard or impossible to get any kind of job where you'd need a national security clearance, which is the kind of job a lot of people hoped to get after they were kicked out.
JDK代码将使你难以甚至不可能获得任何需要国家安全许可的工作，这正是许多人希望在被踢出军队后能得到的工作。
As it was all kind of sinking in, it was really hurtful and felt very scary. But honestly, the next-- like, a day or two later, I just started feeling really indignant. And I was like, you know what? That sounds like a cool new tattoo, JDK.
当这一切沉淀下来时，真的很伤人，感觉很可怕。但老实说，接下来——大约一天或两天后，我开始感到非常愤怒。我就想，你知道吗？那听起来像是个很酷的新纹身，JDK。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Did that make you want to do anything differently, knowing about this code?
知道这个代码后，你有什么想做得不同的吗？
I guess it just sort of steeled my resolve to not self-identify. And I'm going to try to make my exit from the military as much on my terms as possible.
我想这只是坚定了我不自我表露的决心。我会尽我所能让我的军队离职尽可能按照我的方式进行。
I'd never heard Geirid sound like this, just openly defiant. But I was worried this was all going to end in the worst-case scenario for her. She'd get singled out, punished for not self-identifying, and walk away with nothing. It was getting hard to see it going some other way.
我从未听过盖里德听起来像这样，只是公开的反抗。但我担心这最终会演变成对她来说最坏的情况。她会被挑出来，因为没有自我表露而受到惩罚，最后什么也得不到。很难看到事情以其他方式结束。
The deadline came and went. Geirid was still going to work, waiting. But nothing happened. One by one, almost all the trans service members she knew were put on leave, pending separation. One guy Geirid knew, who had also chosen involuntary, got a notice after the deadline passed. He's an instructor at West Point, was up for a promotion, but his name got flagged, and he was put on leave.
截止日期到了。盖里德依然去上班，等待着。但什么也没发生。一个接一个，她认识的几乎所有跨性别军人都被停职，等待分离。盖里德认识的一个人，他也选择了非自愿，在截止日期过后收到了一份通知。他是西点军校的教官，本来有升职机会，但他的名字被标记了，他被停职了。
I couldn't understand why Geirid's name hadn't been flagged too, but it hadn't. She'd drive to work, check in, sit at her desk, look around.
我不明白为什么盖里德的名字没有被标记，但确实没有。她开车去上班，签到，坐在桌子旁，环顾四周。
I'm really starting to feel kind of like, out on this island while everybody else is back on the mainland. And I'm like, am I the only one out here?
我真的开始觉得，当其他人都回到大陆时，我就被困在这个岛上。我就想，我是这里唯一一个还在外面的人吗？
Geirid worried that somebody at her duty station would report her for continuing to show up. At work, she started avoiding the bathroom and the locker rooms, changing in her office or in a closed bathroom stall. She didn't want to raise any alarms. A few weeks later, Geirid got an order to start working from home. It was like one more door closing-- still have a job, can't show up at work. But she'd just work from home as long as she could.
盖里德担心在她的工作站，有人会举报她继续出现。在工作中，她开始避开浴室和更衣室，在办公室或封闭的卫生间隔间里换衣服。她不想引起任何警报。几周后，盖里德接到了在家工作的命令。就像又关上了一扇门——仍然有工作，不能去工作场所。但她只能尽可能在家工作。
And then, in the beginning of August, Geirid texted me. She had some news. She said I should call her. It was gigantic news, it turned out. And it was a good thing. Her medical retirement had come through. When I called, it sounded like she was afraid to get too excited or she'd jinx it.
然后，八月初，盖里德给我发了短信。她有一些消息。她说我应该给她打电话。结果这是一个巨大的消息。而且是件好事。她的医疗退休手续办下来了。我打电话时，听起来她害怕太兴奋，不然会弄巧成拙。
It's slowly been sinking in. And I've been getting more positive feels about it every day as it's sort of sinking in, the reality of what this means.
它慢慢沉淀下来了。我每天都感到更积极，当它沉淀下来时，我明白了这意味着什么。
Here's what it means. Geirid would get a pension for the rest of her life, health insurance for life for her and Chrissy and for both kids until they were adults. She'd be a regular retired veteran, no special JDK code branding her. She'd get an honorable discharge.
这就是它的含义。盖里德终生都能获得养老金，她和克里斯蒂终生都能获得医疗保险，两个孩子在成年之前也能获得。她将是一名普通的退休退伍军人，没有特殊的JDK代码贴在身上。她将获得光荣退伍。
And so I've got somewhere between, say, like 50 days to 90 days to where I'll be a civilian.
所以我大概有50到90天的时间，我就要成为平民了。
Oh my gosh.
噢，天哪。
I know. Holy shit. Like, that's really soon.
我知道。该死。那真的很快。
Turns out, somehow, the best-case scenario in all this was that Geirid had been deemed a permanently and fully disabled veteran.
事实证明，不知何故，这一切中最好的情况是盖里德被认定为永久且完全残疾的退伍军人。
Chrissy's sitting next to me now. She said that she's worried I'm going to use it to get out of doing dishes, [LAUGHS] which I am now.
克里斯蒂现在坐在我旁边。她说她担心我会用它来逃避洗碗，[笑] 我现在确实在用它逃避。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Chrissy, what do you feel about all this?
克里斯蒂，你对这一切有什么感觉？
I feel really lucky, to be honest with you. It took a minute for it to sink in with me, as it usually does. I noticed that that day, I felt happy. [LAUGHS] There's a moment in the movie Bad Guys where the wolf shakes his tail because he did something nice, and his tail wags.
老实说，我感到很幸运。我花了一点时间才接受它，通常都是这样。我注意到那天，我感到很高兴。[笑] 电影《坏蛋联盟》里有个片段，狼摇尾巴是因为他做了件好事，然后他的尾巴摇了起来。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I, like, turned around, and my tail was wagging. It's like, what is this?
我就转过身，我的尾巴也摇了起来。就像是，这是什么？
So how do you square this kind of process of persecution for who you are leading to this outcome?
那么，你如何平衡这种因为你的身份而受到的迫害导致了这种结果的过程？
I was thinking about a way to answer a question like that while Chrissy was talking, and I don't have a good answer. I think this is all really raw right now. So the most clear way to look at it, I think, at this moment--
当克里斯蒂说话时，我正在思考如何回答这样的问题，我没有好的答案。我觉得这一切现在还很新鲜。所以在这个时刻，我认为最清楚的看待方式是——
Geirid started talking about this outcome in a really passive way, as if she and Chrissy hadn't been meticulously planning and mapping out all the different options, as if she hadn't pushed to submit all the paperwork for the medical retirement and stayed on top of every detail.
盖里德开始以一种非常被动的方式谈论这个结果，好像她和克里斯蒂没有在精心策划和映射所有的不同选项，好像她没有推动提交所有医疗退休的文书并跟进每一个细节。
It was fortuitous that the medical review board process got started before all of the policies started rolling out after the executive order.
在行政命令发布后所有的政策开始推出之前，医疗审查委员会的过程就已经开始，这很幸运。
Mm-hmm. I mean, that was your strategy.
嗯。我的意思是，那是你的策略。
Yeah. I mean, that was a hope, to try to get that option on the table.
是的。我的意思是，那是一个希望，试图把那个选项摆到台面上。
[CLEARS THROAT] Hi. I think that Geirid's trying to sound very circumspect and not like we made this happen 100,000% and everybody just needs to deal with it. But we have been gaming this. What? Like, not gaming, but we've built a future. We knew this shit would happen. And we worked to build a future based on-- we worked to make lemonade out of these fucking lemons.
[清嗓子] 嗨。我认为盖里德试图表现得非常谨慎，而不是说我们百分之百实现了这一点，而每个人只需要接受它。但我们一直在玩这场游戏。什么？就像，不是玩游戏，而是我们建立了一个未来。我们知道这事会发生。我们努力建立了一个未来，基于——我们努力从这些该死的柠檬里榨出柠檬汁。
And then you get to have a pension and be rewarded for the sacrifice you made to join the military to take care of us. I mean--
然后你就能得到养老金，并因你加入军队照顾我们所做的牺牲而得到回报。我的意思是——
I just don't like the gaming. That sounds like--
我只是不喜欢玩游戏那个词。那听起来像——
That's not sneaky. That's not Bad News Bears. You made a plan. And our plan worked. That's OK.
那不卑鄙。那不是烂电影。你制定了一个计划。我们的计划奏效了。那没关系。
Oh, god.
噢，天哪。
What? Give yourself some credit.
什么？给自己一点赞美。
What are you feeling, Geirid?
你感觉如何，盖里德？
I'm feeling like I'm still drawing a military paycheck, so I cannot agree or disagree with anything my wife just said on the record.
我觉得我还在领军队的薪水，所以我不能在记录上同意或不同意我妻子刚才说的任何事情。
[LAUGHS] We are just protecting our family.
[笑] 我们只是在保护我们的家庭。
Yeah, strategically and methodically marching through the halls of a very complex bureaucratic system until we found the right door to open. And now we're going to walk through it.
是的，战略性且有条不紊地穿过一个非常复杂的官僚系统的走廊，直到我们找到正确的门。现在我们要走进去了。
The happy solution that Geirid and Chrissy found, it was pretty rare. Most of the people I talked to got discharged over the winter. And even the ones who pivoted really fast-- started school or found a new job-- they told me they were struggling and disoriented, wrecks, mental health wise. Geirid and Chrissy's safe landing was like one bright spot, borne out of skill and a smile from some god of fortune that most people weren't going to get.
盖里德和克里斯蒂找到的这个快乐的解决方案非常罕见。我采访的大多数人在冬天就退伍了。即使是那些转型很快的人——开始上学或找到新工作——她们告诉我她们在挣扎和迷失方向，心理健康方面一团糟。盖里德和克里斯蒂的安全着陆就像是一个亮点，源于技巧和好运之神的一个微笑，而大多数人是得不到这些的。
There are so many efforts right now by our federal government to pry entire groups of people away from their jobs, their communities, their lives as they've been living them. This particular effort to purge trans people from the military stands out to me, not only because all of them are serving their country, making sacrifices so many people have no interest in making, but also because who is allowed in the military tends to be a kind of signal for the rest of America.
现在我们的联邦政府有太多的努力试图将整个群体的人从他们的工作、社区、生活中剥离出来。这次特别是将跨性别者从军队中清洗出去的努力让我印象深刻，不仅是因为他们所有人都在为国效力，做出很多人没有兴趣做出的牺牲，还因为谁被允许进入军队往往是美国其余部分的一个信号。
Who is allowed to wear our uniform? Who belongs here? Who are we as a country? And for the last year, the government has been putting on a pretty flashy show of forcing out this one group of people only because of who they are. There have, of course, been decades of case law making that extremely hard to do because it's discriminatory and unconstitutional. But here we are.
谁被允许穿上我们的制服？谁属于这里？我们作为一个国家是谁？过去一年，政府一直在上演一场相当炫目的表演，强迫这一群人离开，仅仅因为他们是谁。当然，几十年来都有判例法使这极其困难，因为这是歧视性的和违宪的。但我们还是走到了这一步。
Geirid finally retired a few weeks ago. She and Chrissy thought about having her ceremony at a gay bar but decided just to do something small with family. They're planning a trip to Germany later this summer for them and the kids, you know, keeping their options open.
盖里德几周前终于退休了。她和克里斯蒂想过在同性恋酒吧举行仪式，但决定只是和家人做点小事。她们正计划今年夏天晚些时候为她们和孩子去德国旅行，你知道，保持她们的选择开放。
That story was produced by Miki Meek and edited by Nancy Updike and Chana Joffe-Walt.
那个故事由米基·米克制作，南希·厄普代克和查娜·乔菲-沃尔特编辑。
Act Three, Beast Friends Furr-Ever. To end our show today, another story of two people facing a huge disruption to life as they know it. But instead of making a million different plans, they have just one single, very consequential choice to make. It's from a new book of short stories by Rachel Khong. In this one, God has given up on humans. It starts like this.
第三幕，毛茸茸的好友。结束我们今天的节目，另一个关于两个人面临生活巨大变动的故事。但她们没有制定一百万个不同的计划，而是只有一个非常重要的选择。它来自雷切尔·孔的新书。在这篇故事里，上帝已经放弃了人类。故事是这样开始的。
"And on the 2,556,750,000th day, God reconsidered what he had made and decided that the world would be much better off if humans were other animals entirely, if there were no such thing as human beings at all." And then God gives every single person one choice. Here's the story.
“在第2,556,750,000天，上帝重新思考了他所创造的一切，并决定如果人类完全变成其他动物，如果根本就没有人类这回事，世界会好得多。”然后上帝给了每个人一个选择。故事如下。
Jade was at her best friend Ruby's house when both of their phones pinged with the news, like it was an Amber Alert or a hurricane warning. At the end of the month, God declared, all people would be transformed. Ruby, Jade, and the rest of humanity would have 30 days to select what they wanted to spend the rest of their lives as. They had the entire animal kingdom to choose from.
当她们两个人的手机响着新闻推送时，杰德正在好朋友鲁比家，就像安珀警报或飓风预警。上帝宣布，在月底，所有人都将发生转变。鲁比、杰德和全人类将有30天的时间选择她们想作为什么度过余生。她们可以选择整个动物王国。
After the deadline, humans would not exist.
截止日期之后，人类将不复存在。
Jade was straining pasta over Ruby's sink. The hot steam rose into her face, a carbohydrate facial. Ruby stirred the pot of sauce over the stove.
杰德正在鲁比的水槽上沥干意面。滚烫的蒸汽升到她脸上，一种碳水化合物美容法。鲁比在炉子上的锅里搅拌着酱汁。
"What animals have friends?" Jade asked Ruby.
“哪些动物有朋友？”杰德问鲁比。
Ruby typed the question into her phone.
鲁比在手机上输入了这个问题。
"Cetaceans are capable of true friendship," Ruby read. "Higher primates, elephants, camelids, certain members of the horse family."
“鲸类动物有真正的友谊，”鲁比读道。“高等灵长类、大象、骆驼科动物、马科动物的某些成员。”
"Camelids are camels?" Jade asked.
“骆驼科动物是骆驼吗？”杰德问。
"And llamas and alpacas."
“还有大羊驼和羊驼。”
They sat down to eat their dinner. Ruby poured their wine into her favorite little museum-store glasses, which were shaped like egg cups.
她们坐下来吃晚饭。鲁比把葡萄酒倒进她最喜欢的博物馆小商店玻璃杯里，杯子形状像鸡蛋托。
"What animals get drunk?" Ruby asked.
“哪些动物会喝醉？”鲁比问。
"That one I know," Jade laughed. Elephants and parrots. Deer, moose, bats.
“那个我知道，”杰德笑着说。大象和鹦鹉。鹿、驼鹿、蝙蝠。
"So elephants have friends and get drunk," Ruby mused.
“所以大象有朋友，还会喝醉，”鲁比沉思道。
Jade twirled spaghetti around her fork and conveyed it to her mouth. "What'd you put in this? It's so good."
杰德用叉子卷起意面，送进嘴里。“你放了什么？太好吃了。”
"Fish sauce. You like it?"
“鱼露。你喜欢吗？”
"I'm going to miss your cooking."
“我会想念你做的菜。”
"You won't, though," Ruby said, laughing sadly. "I mean, that's the kind of beautiful thing."
“你不会的，”鲁比难过地笑着说。“我的意思是，这就是美好之处。”
For the first two weeks after the announcement, political bickering paused. Instead, zoologists were in high demand, appearing on television shows, looking a bit confused by their newfound fame. Nature programs saw a surge in viewership and revenue. "What's your choice?" people asked one another. Everyone everywhere was trying to make sense of things, ferret out the superior choice.
公告发布后的前两周，政治争吵暂停了。取而代之的是，动物学家很吃香，出现在电视节目上，对他们新获得的声誉感到有点困惑。自然节目见证了收视率和收入的激增。“你的选择是什么？”人们问对方。每个人都在试图理清头绪，找出更优的选择。
Ruby thought it was ludicrous. The point was to be freed of trivial human concerns, and yet, humans were already trying to extrapolate based on human social conventions, like romance and marriage. Penguins were well publicized as animals that mated it for life. Many, many people wanted to be penguins. But were we going to have a world full of penguins when it was getting so warm?
鲁比认为这很荒谬。重点是从琐碎的人类烦恼中解放出来，然而，人类已经在尝试基于人类社会习俗进行推断，比如浪漫和婚姻。企鹅作为终身伴侣的动物而被广泛宣传。很多很多人想成为企鹅。但在天气变得越来越暖和的时候，我们还要一个满是企鹅的世界吗？
28 days before the deadline, Jade and Ruby met at their favorite old movie theater. At the concession stand, Jade ordered a large popcorn from an acne-riddled teen named Halvor.
距离截止日期还有28天，杰德和鲁比在她们最喜欢的老电影院见面。在小卖部，杰德从一个满脸痘痘的青少年哈尔沃那里点了大份爆米花。
"What's your choice?" Jade asked Halvor. It was small talk now.
“你的选择是什么？”杰德问哈尔沃。现在这成了客套话。
"Electric eel," Halvor said.
“电鳗，”哈尔沃说。
"Very cool," Jade replied.
“很酷，”杰德回答。
In the darkened theater, Ruby produced the friends' preferred condiments from her purse-- furikake, sea salt, a double-bagged baby food jar of melted real butter.
在漆黑的电影院里，鲁比从钱包里掏出了朋友们最喜欢的调味品——海苔芝麻粉、海盐、一个双层密封的装有融化真黄油的婴儿食品罐。
They had been friends since they were six years old. That was 30 years of being friends. At six, they'd made perfume together by steeping rose petals in water. At 12, they practiced freak dancing. At 18, Ruby held Jade's hair back as she puked from too many Jell-O shots. They knew which movie the other wanted to see without asking.
她们从六岁起就是朋友了。那是30年的友谊。六岁时，她们一起把玫瑰花瓣浸在水里做香水。12岁时，她们练习怪诞舞蹈。18岁时，鲁比帮杰德扶着头发，因为她喝了太多果冻酒而呕吐。她们不用问就知道对方想看哪部电影。
The friends emerge from the darkened theater, their eyes squinting to adjust to the light. Ruby loved the movie. But she could tell from the neutral expression on Jade's face that Jade hadn't liked the film, so she tempered her enthusiasm. It happened more frequently than you would think, that someone you loved loved different things than you.
朋友们从漆黑的电影院走出来，眼睛眯着适应光线。鲁比很喜欢这部电影。但从杰德中性的表情可以看出她不喜欢，所以鲁比收敛了她的热情。这种情况发生的频率比你想象的要高，你爱的人和你爱着不同的东西。
At their favorite pho restaurant, Jade ordered for the both of them.
在她们最喜欢的越南河粉店，杰德帮两人点了餐。
"Animals that get the most sleep," Ruby said, "are sloths, koalas, bats, armadillos, cats."
“睡眠时间最长的动物，”鲁比说，“是树懒、考拉、蝙蝠、犰狳、猫。”
"You know, bats sleep a lot and get drunk, so those are pluses," said Jade. "But they gross me out."
“你知道，蝙蝠睡得多，还会喝醉，所以这些是加分项，”杰德说。“但它们让我恶心。”
"You're only finding them gross because of your humanness. You wouldn't find yourself gross as a bat. You wouldn't, like, consider yourself in any reflective surfaces."
“你只是因为你的人类身份才觉得它们恶心。作为一只蝙蝠，你不会觉得自己恶心。你不会在任何反射表面审视自己。”
Their pho arrived, pink lily pads of rare meat, thin rings of white onion. They were both artists, Jade a painter and Ruby a novelist, but Ruby had always been the more practical of the two. It was what it was. Ruby disliked her own practicality. While everyone was busy being upset that they would be transformed into non-Homo sapiens, Ruby had come up with a spreadsheet of animals, listing the pros and cons of each.
她们的河粉端上来了，粉红色的稀有肉片睡莲叶，薄薄的白洋葱圈。她们都是艺术家，杰德是画家，鲁比是小说家，但鲁比一直是两人中更务实的一个。事实就是如此。鲁比不喜欢自己的务实。当每个人都忙于因为即将被转化为非智人而感到不安时，鲁比列出了一张动物电子表格，列出了每种动物的利弊。
"Don't make fun of me," Jade admitted, "but I'm thinking of seeing an astrologer."
“别笑我，”杰德承认，“但我正考虑去见一位占星师。”
"Jade!" Ruby said, shocked.
“杰德！”鲁比震惊地说。
"I knew I shouldn't mention it."
“我就知道我不该提的。”
"No. I'm sorry. Of course you should. I'll be curious to hear what they think."
“不。我很抱歉。你当然应该去。我很想听听她们怎么想。”
Even though there was less than a month left of capitalism itself, businesses were still springing up, consultants who claimed to be able to look into your soul via your eyes and tell you exactly what animal you were meant to be.
尽管资本主义本身只剩下不到一个月的时间了，但企业依然不断涌现，咨询师声称可以通过你的眼睛窥视你的灵魂，告诉你你注定要成为什么动物。
"What animals experience sexual pleasure?" Jade asked Ruby.
“哪些动物会经历性快感？”杰德问鲁比。
"Dolphins, maybe."
“海豚，也许。”
"Don't Dolphins seem so, I don't know, basic? The golden retrievers of cetaceans."
“海豚看起来不是很，我不知道，基础吗？鲸类动物里的金毛寻回犬。”
"Definitely." Jade dipped a raw beansprout in sriracha.
“确实。”杰德把生的绿豆芽蘸在是拉差辣椒酱里。
"We should be together, though, you and me. Don't you think?"
“但我们应该在一起，你和我。你不觉得吗？”
"Not as penguins," Ruby said. "I refuse to be a penguin."
“不是作为企鹅，”鲁比说。“我拒绝成为企鹅。”
"We won't be penguins."
“我们不会成为企鹅的。”
"I wonder if God would let us be rocks," Ruby joked. "Jade and Ruby, stay who we are, forever."
“我想知道上帝是否会让我们成为岩石，”鲁比开玩笑道。“杰德和鲁比，保持现在的样子，永远。”
One week remained. Ruby wanted to bask in the most human things. What were they? To her, they were domestic tasks that most others found unspectacular-- cooking noodles, solving crossword puzzles, pumicing her rough feet, responding to emails with "Sorry for my delay in getting back to you." She even savored, for the first time, sitting in traffic on her way to Jade's apartment.
还剩一周。鲁比想沉浸在最人类的事情中。那是什么？对她来说，是大多数人觉得无聊的家务活——煮面条、填字游戏、用浮石磨粗糙的脚、回复电子邮件说“很抱歉回复延迟”。她甚至第一次细细品味了去杰德公寓路上堵车的时光。
"What's the most human thing we could do right now?" Jade asked.
“我们现在能做的最像人类的事情是什么？”杰德问。
"Escape an escape room? Bake a multilayered cake?"
“逃离密室？烤多层蛋糕？”
Jade nodded. "Let's bake a cake and do an escape room."
杰德点点头。“让我们烤个蛋糕，玩个密室逃脱。”
They were frosting the cake when Jade, using the offset spatula to smooth the frosting around the cake sides, spoke up.
她们正在给蛋糕抹霜时，杰德用抹刀把蛋糕侧面的霜抹平，开口说道。
"I think I want to be a whale," Jade said. She seemed nervous to be saying this out loud. And Ruby turned, surprised, to her friend. It was the first time either of them had expressed a real desire. Until that moment, they'd only brought up possibilities in a joking way.
“我想成为一条鲸鱼，”杰德说。她大声说出这句话时似乎很紧张。鲁比转过身，对她的朋友感到惊讶。这是她们中第一次有人表达真实的愿望。在那之前，她们只是开玩笑地提过可能性。
"Oh, wow," Ruby said. She tried not to seem too surprised or at all alarmed. "What kind?"
“噢，哇，”鲁比说。她试着不表现得太惊讶或太惊慌。“哪种？”
"Bowhead whales live to 200."
“露脊鲸可以活到200岁。”
"I don't know if I want to live that long," Ruby said slowly.
“我不知道我是否想活那么久，”鲁比慢慢地说。
"Really?" Jade asked. "Don't you think it would be fun, being in the same pod for 200 years?"
“真的吗？”杰德问。“你不觉得在一个鲸群里待200年很有趣吗？”
"I would love to be in your pod," Ruby assured.
“我很乐意加入你的鲸群，”鲁比保证道。
"What if we chose a shorter-lived whale? Blue whales only live 80 or 90." Jade's voice had a tinge of desperation in it. "Or beluga whales, they live to 50. Plus, they're cute."
“如果我们选择一种寿命较短的鲸鱼呢？蓝鲸只能活80或90岁。”杰德的声音里带着一丝绝望。“或者白鲸，它们活到50岁。而且，它们很可爱。”
"We won't know that we're cute."
“我们不知道我们是否可爱。”
"Don't be like that, Ruby," Jade said. Tears were gathering in her eyes. "Be honest with me. Could you be a whale?"
“别这样，鲁比，”杰德说。泪水在她的眼里聚集。“对我诚实一点。你能成为一条鲸鱼吗？”
"I don't know, Jade," Ruby said. "I have to think about it. I'm sorry."
“我不知道，杰德，”鲁比说。“我必须考虑一下。我很抱歉。”
They sliced and ate the cake in silence. When it came time for their escape room appointment, Jade told Ruby she wasn't in the mood.
她们默默地切开并吃掉了蛋糕。当到了密室逃脱预约时间时，杰德告诉鲁比她没心情。
"Actually, I think I'd rather be alone right now," Jade said.
“实际上，我觉得我现在想一个人待着，”杰德说。
"OK," Ruby said. "Of course. No problem." She took her car keys from Jade's kitchen counter. Then she hugged her friend, who returned her embrace stiffly.
“好吧，”鲁比说。“当然。没问题。”她从杰德的厨房柜台上拿了车钥匙。然后她拥抱了她的朋友，朋友僵硬地回抱了她。
All her life, Ruby had felt like a weirdo. What other people had-- groups of friends, romantic partners, weddings, where they were treated like celebrities, spacious houses, adorable and well-behaved children-- Ruby had never wanted. She wasn't shirking these things as a point of identity, but simply because she had always viewed them as extraneous, empty. Only two things made her feel like she wasn't completely inhuman. One was working, immersing herself in her writing. The other was being around Jade. Only Jade had witnessed Ruby in every iteration of her life and not fled. Why couldn't Ruby agree to be a whale? It could be so simple.
一生中，鲁比一直觉得像个怪人。其他人拥有的——朋友群体、浪漫伴侣、婚礼，她们被像名人一样对待，宽敞的房子，可爱且听话的孩子——鲁比从来没想要过。她不是为了标榜身份而逃避这些，仅仅是因为她一直认为这些是无关紧要的、空虚的。只有两件事让她觉得她不是完全非人类。一是工作，沉浸在写作中。二是和杰德在一起。只有杰德见证了她生命中的每一个阶段，却没有逃走。为什么鲁比不能同意成为鲸鱼？那可以很简单。
32 hours remained. Jade and Ruby carpooled to their friend Cassandra's house. In their larger friend circle, everyone had been throwing extravagant parties, trying to spend all the money they could before money no longer mattered. Last week, they attended a party where a turducken sat on an enormous doily. The host sliced neatly into it with an electric carving knife, exposing the wonders within, a breathtaking meat geode.
还剩32小时。杰德和鲁比拼车去了她们的朋友卡珊德拉家。在她们更大的朋友圈里，每个人都在举行奢华派对，试图在金钱不再重要之前花光所有的钱。上周，她们参加了一个派对，一个“火鸡鸭”坐在巨大的蕾丝垫纸上。主人用电动切割刀整齐地切开它，露出了里面的奇迹，一个令人叹为观止的肉之晶洞。
Cassandra welcomed them. She wore a silk dress that draped beautifully across her round, uniquely human breasts. Servers circulated with champagne flutes and crystal dishes of the finest beluga caviar. Jade and Ruby were pleased to see their friends enjoying themselves, but as usual, the two of them wound up talking to each other. Ruby's parents planned to be turtle doves, and her younger brother would be a partridge. They were irritated with her for not wanting to be a bird along with them. Ruby's mother was so bereft that she wouldn't speak to her.
卡珊德拉欢迎她们。她穿着一件丝绸裙子，优美地垂在她圆润、独特的人类乳房上。服务生们分发着香槟杯和装有顶级白鲸鱼子酱的水晶盘。杰德和鲁比很高兴看到朋友们玩得很开心，但像往常一样，她们两个最终还是只跟对方说话。鲁比的父母打算成为斑鸠，她的弟弟会成为鹧鸪。她们因为她不想和她们一起成为鸟而恼火。鲁比的母亲悲痛欲绝，以至于不跟她说话。
"What are you thinking?" Jade asked finally. The friends had been avoiding the question all night, wanting to enjoy the party.
“你在想什么？”杰德最后问。朋友们整晚都在回避这个问题，想要享受派对。
"I think," Ruby said slowly, watching her friend's face, "I think I want to be a turtle."
“我想，”鲁比慢慢地说，注视着她朋友的脸，“我想成为一只乌龟。”
Ruby had abandoned her spreadsheet. She couldn't explain it, but Ruby felt, deep in her bones, that she wanted to be a turtle.
鲁比抛弃了她的电子表格。她无法解释，但鲁比在骨子里觉得她想成为一只乌龟。
Jade loaded a potato chip with caviar, placed the entirety of it on her tongue, and chewed for a long moment.
杰德在薯片上放了鱼子酱，把它整片放在舌头上，咀嚼了很久。
"But turtles live even longer than whales," Jade said, as neutrally as she could manage.
“但乌龟活得比鲸鱼还要久，”杰德尽可能中性地说。
"I guess it wasn't about the lifespan at all," Ruby admitted. "I don't know if I can explain it."
“我想这根本与寿命无关，”鲁比承认。“我不知道我能不能解释清楚。”
"A freshwater turtle?"
“一种淡水龟？”
"I don't think I want to be a sea turtle, unfortunately."
“不幸的是，我觉得我不想成为海龟。”
"So we won't even be in the same body of water."
“所以我们甚至不会在同一个水域。”
"I know, Jade. I'm sorry. You can't let me hold you back from being a whale."
“我知道，杰德。我很抱歉。你不能让我阻碍你成为鲸鱼。”
Jade said nothing.
杰德没说话。
"Please, please don't be mad at me," Ruby said. "I couldn't stand it if you were mad at me in our last--" she looked at her watch-- "29 hours."
“请，请别生我的气，”鲁比说。“如果你在我们最后的——”她看了看手表——“29小时里生我的气，我受不了。”
Jade said nothing still.
杰德依然没说话。
"I'm just sad," Jade said finally. "I'll miss you."
“我只是很伤心，”杰德最后说。“我会想念你的。”
"You won't actually--"
“你实际上不会——”
"Stop it, Ruby," Jade said angrily. "Don't tell me I won't be able to miss." Tears fell down her cheeks in pronounced, dramatic rivulets. "I will miss you."
“闭嘴，鲁比，”杰德愤怒地说。“别告诉我我将无法想念。”泪水顺着她的脸颊流下，形成明显、夸张的细流。“我会想念你的。”
"And I'll miss you, Jade," Ruby said. She told herself she wouldn't, but she started crying too.
“我也会想念你的，杰德，”鲁比说。她告诉自己她不会，但她也开始哭了。
Jade slept over at Ruby's. In the morning, they indulged in a hungover feast of painkillers and waffles and bacon, which Ruby made extra crispy, the way Jade liked. Afterward, they climbed onto Ruby's roof and threw dirty dishes off the side of it because they didn't need to wash them anymore. The dishes shattered satisfyingly on the asphalt. That evening, Ruby and Jade visited their families. At the front door, Ruby hugged her father and brother. Her mother was still too upset to speak with her, so Ruby left a handwritten note that she hoped sufficiently expressed how much she loved her.
杰德在鲁比家过夜。早上，她们沉迷于宿醉后的盛宴，止痛药、华夫饼和培根，鲁比把培根做得格外酥脆，就像杰德喜欢的那样。之后，她们爬上鲁比的屋顶，把脏盘子扔了下去，因为她们不再需要洗它们了。盘子在柏油路上破碎的声音令人满意。那天晚上，鲁比和杰德去见了家人。在前门，鲁比拥抱了父亲和弟弟。母亲仍然太伤心，不能跟她说话，所以鲁比留下了一张手写的字条，希望它能充分表达她有多爱她。
Back at Ruby's house, they popped popcorn and watched Chungking Express. Over the years, they'd found the film charming and then annoying and now charming again. They brushed and flossed their teeth, not because they had to, but because sleeping with clean teeth felt nice. Lights out, lying side by side, they began to talk the way they had when they were girls having sleepovers.
回到鲁比家，她们爆了爆米花，看了《重庆森林》。这些年来，她们发现这部电影时而迷人，时而讨厌，现在又迷人了。她们刷牙并用牙线清洁，不是因为必须这样做，而是因为清洁的牙齿睡觉感觉很舒服。熄灯后，并排躺着，她们开始像女孩们举行睡衣派对时那样交谈。
Earlier that day, they had texted their final decisions to God-- whale for Jade and turtle for Ruby-- and received brown thumbs-up emojis. At 4:00 in the morning their time, all of humanity would evaporate. Each person would be transformed and placed in a suitable habitat.
那天早些时候，她们向上帝发送了最后的决定——杰德是鲸鱼，鲁比是乌龟——并收到了棕色的点赞表情符号。在她们时间凌晨4点，全人类将蒸发。每个人都将被转化并安置在合适的栖息地。
"Remember that time we raced snails?" Jade asked. Ruby could hear her smiling in the dark. "And my mom got so mad because it was dinnertime and the snails were too slow?"
“还记得我们有次比赛蜗牛吗？”杰德问。鲁比可以听到她在黑暗中微笑。“我妈妈当时特别生气，因为是晚餐时间，蜗牛太慢了？”
"I remember!" said Ruby. "And we brought them inside in our pockets to race in the bathtub."
“我记得！”鲁比说。“我们把它们揣进兜里带回家，在浴缸里比赛。”
"Delilah and Joseph."
“黛利拉和约瑟夫。”
"I can't believe you remember that."
“真不敢相信你还记得那个。”
They lay in the silence for a long moment.
她们在沉默中躺了很久。
"Do you want to be conscious when this happens," Ruby asked? "Or should we try to get some sleep?"
“当这发生时，你想保持清醒吗？”鲁比问，“还是我们应该试着睡会儿？”
"I don't know. What about you?"
“我不知道。你呢？”
"I don't know either."
“我也不知道。”
There was another long silence.
又是长久的沉默。
"Jade, I'm sorry that--" Ruby paused.
“杰德，我很抱歉——”鲁比停住了。
There were so many things she needed to apologize for that she didn't even know where to begin-- the time she neglected her friend because she believed her work was paramount, the time she knew Jade was going through difficulties but hadn't known what to say.
有太多事情她需要道歉，以至于她甚至不知道从哪里开始——她忽视朋友的时间，因为她认为工作至上；当她知道杰德经历困难时，她却不知道该说什么的时间。
During those periods, she'd cooked bulk meals for Jade and mopped Jade's floor. She knew Jade would have liked verbal reassurance too, but Ruby didn't know how to offer it. She never would now.
在那些时期，她为杰德批量做了饭，拖了杰德的地板。她知道杰德也会想要口头安慰，但鲁比不知道如何表达。她永远也不会知道如何表达了。
"It's OK, Ruby." Jade's voice was clear and steady. "I know. I know you."
“没关系，鲁比。”杰德的声音清晰且坚定。“我知道。我了解你。”
"I don't think I can sleep," Jade said.
“我觉得我睡不着，”杰德说。
"Me neither."
“我也一样。”
"Should we do something else?"
“我们要不要做点别的？”
Ruby stood up and turned the lights on. She peeked out the window and saw that other lights were on too.
鲁比站起来，打开了灯。她窥视窗外，看到别人家也亮着灯。
"What about--" Ruby thought, "what about YouTube karaoke?"
“什么叫——”鲁比想，“什么叫YouTube卡拉OK？”
"I have a good one. Hang on." Ruby angled her laptop away from Jade so that the song selection would be a surprise. The familiar notes of "Pachelbel's Canon in D" came on. Jade broke into laughter, delighted. They didn't need the lyrics.
“我有首好的。等下。”鲁比把笔记本电脑从杰德面前移开，这样歌曲选择会是一个惊喜。《帕赫贝尔的D大调卡农》那熟悉的音符响起。杰德爆发出一阵大笑，非常开心。她们不需要歌词。
"La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la," Ruby and Jade sang together at the top of their lungs. They put their phones down and, with their arms around each other's waists, were singing as loudly as they had ever sung, when in a moment, a hundredth of a second, Ruby and Jade vaporized with the rest of humanity, atoms scattering, traveling, reassembling, Jade in the Pacific Ocean and Ruby in an Australian pond.
“啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，”鲁比和杰德一起声嘶力竭地唱着。她们放下手机，腰间拥抱着彼此，唱得比她们以往任何时候都要大声，就在那一瞬间，百分之一秒，鲁比和杰德随着全人类一起气化，原子四散、漂流、重组，杰德在太平洋，鲁比在澳大利亚的池塘里。
But, as to be expected with such an enormous undertaking, there was a glitch. For a fraction of a second, Jade, in the body of a blue whale, and Ruby, in the body of a freshwater turtle, sustained human thoughts. Jade thought, Ruby. And Ruby thought, Jade. Then God put his divine palm to his divine face and corrected the error. From then on, Jade swam, and Ruby basked in the sun's warm rays. And God looked upon everything that he had made, and behold, it was very good.
但是，正如预期的那样，如此庞大的工程出现了故障。在那百分之一秒里，蓝鲸身体里的杰德，和淡水龟身体里的鲁比，保留了人类的思维。杰德想，鲁比。鲁比想，杰德。然后上帝把神圣的手掌放在了神圣的脸上，纠正了错误。从那以后，杰德游动着，鲁比在阳光温暖的光束下晒太阳。上帝看他所创造的一切，看，非常好。
This story was read for us by actor Melissa Tang and produced by Diane Wu. You can read the full version of this story, "D-Day," in Rachel Khong's new book of short stories, My Dear You.
这个故事由演员梅丽莎·唐为我们朗读，戴安·吴制作。你可以在雷切尔·孔的新短篇小说集《亲爱的你》中阅读这个故事的完整版本，“D-Day”。
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek and edited by Chana Joffe-Walt. Editorial help from Sonner Kehrt. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Adriene Lilly, Stowe Nelson, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ruthie Petitto, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由米基·米克制作，查娜·乔菲-沃尔特编辑。索纳·克特提供了编辑帮助。今天节目制作人员包括菲亚·本宁、佐伊·蔡斯、艾德丽安·莉莉、斯托·尼尔森、莫莉·马塞洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、鲁西·佩蒂托、纳迪亚·雷曼、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、瑞恩·鲁梅里、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和朱莉·惠特克。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks to Lieutenant Nicolas Talbott, Commander Emily Shilling, Major Erica Vandal, major Julie Clavier, Captain Gordon Herrero, Senior Master Sergeant Jamie Hash, Specialist Wendelyn O, Priya Rashid, Emily Starbuck Gerson, Shannon Minter, Jennifer Levi, Amanda Johnston, Malkia Hutchinson, Lauren Gray, Sabrina Hyman, Kae Petrin, Yowei Shaw, Kyle Pulley, Lindsay Church and Minority Veterans of America, and the organization SPARTA Pride.
特别感谢尼古拉斯·塔尔博特少尉、艾米丽·席林少校、艾丽卡·范达尔少校、朱莉·克拉维尔少校、戈登·埃雷罗上尉、资深大师军士杰米·哈希、专家温德琳·O、普里亚·拉希德、艾米丽·斯塔巴克·格森、香农·明特、詹妮弗·利维、阿曼达·约翰斯顿、马尔基亚·哈钦森、劳伦·格雷、萨布丽娜·海曼、凯·佩特林、萧耀威、凯尔·普利、林赛·丘奇和美国少数族裔退伍军人组织，以及组织SPARTA Pride。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Please consider supporting the show as a This American Life partner. You'll get regular, exclusive bonus episodes, listen ad free, and more. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. Movie night with him is always the same thing. I brainstorm a ton of ideas, but he only wants to watch his favorite movie for the thousandth time. Any movie I suggest is met with the same response.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。请考虑作为《美国生活》的合作伙伴支持本节目。你将获得定期的独家加长剧集，无广告收听等。请在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners加入。像往常一样，感谢我的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。和他一起看电影总是这样。我头脑风暴出一大堆想法，但他只想看他最喜欢的电影第一千次。我建议的任何电影都会得到同样的反应。
That's not Bad News Bears.
那不是烂电影。
I'm Laura Starecheski. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基。我们下周会回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。